[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture
aujourd'hui nous sommes à déclic théâtre
compagnie un théâtrale fondée en 1993 à
trappes on fait le point sur ses
diverses activités et événements à venir
mais avant cela la
compagnie de théâtre fondée en 1993 à
trappes déclic théâtre est désormais
ancrée dans la vie locale de la ville
nous parlerons de ses activités ces
événements à venir comme le championnat
intercollèges de match d'improvisation
théâtrale de saint quentin en yvelines
la compagnie de théâtre fonctionne en
plusieurs pôles le plus important le
match d'improvisation théâtrale des
ateliers proposés aux jeunes sont menées
chaque semaine par des membres de la
compagnie est enfin né en 2001 la radio
marmite fm a été créée par déclic
théâtre cette radio locale à vocation
citoyenne éducative et culturelle est
animée à 60% par des bénévoles
[Musique]
je me trouve dans les locaux de déclic
théâtre cette compagnie de théâtre né en
1993 située à trappes elle le comprend
plusieurs pôles géraldine orquera
bonjour je vous êtes la directrice de la
structure noël yakine louise bonjour
vous êtes chargé du secteur un pro de la
compagnie alors vous allez bientôt fêter
vos trente ans d'existence l'année
prochaine donc en 2023 vous êtes bien
connue des trappistes désormais comment
vous est ancrée dans la vie locale
durant toutes ces années et bien
effectivement on fêtera nos 30 ans
l'année prochaine l'ancrage il s'est
fait dès le départ en 93 même avant il y
avait déjà des projets qui est qui qui
s'était construit auparavant on sait en
créer directement en milieu scolaire
c'était un peu de manière atypique de se
développer pour une compagnie de théâtre
à l'époque est effectivement dès le
départ on s'est ancré dans en milieu
scolaire alors je les il ya plusieurs
pôles en le premier peut-être le plus
important c'est le pôle improvisation
l'essentiel des activités est axé autour
du match d'improvisation théâtrale nour
el yakine est ce que vous pouvez
peut-être me présenter ce premier axe
ben oui le oui effectivement c'est
autour de l'improvisation théâtrale
concon conforme la plupart de nos
comédiens dans un premier temps
le match d'improvisation est un outil en
fait donc qui est né au québec qui a été
importé en france et qui permet en fait
la rencontre des gens déjà sur un bassin
comme saint-quentin ça nous paraît
important que les que les gens arrivent
à se côtoyer autrement que par le sport
dans différentes disciplines tout cas
dans cette discipline artistique et le
match d'improvisation et ben en fait
c'est porteur de valeurs de valeurs de
fair-play des coûte 2 après de
concentration et puis surtout en milieu
scolaire ce qui est super intéressant
c'est que ça permet aussi de d'élargir
et s'intéresser à des registres des
auteurs pour enrichir en fait sont
planel d'improvisateur en fait et c'est
super intéressant pour ça en tout cas
quelle est la fréquence du coût des
activités est ce que c'est donc tous les
mercredis des ateliers plus tôt est-ce
que c'est tous les mercredis les
vendredis commence en général on essaye
de travailler
avec des ateliers une fois par semaine à
hauteur d'une à deux heures par semaine
selon les emplois du temps possible si
c'est en milieu scolaire ou pas par
exemple et
et puis après we had et on organise des
ateliers tout au long de l'année on vous
l'avait dit donc des ateliers toute
l'année nous nous avons pu assister à
l'un d'entre eux regarder
ils ont entre 12 et 14 ans ces jeunes
participent tous les mercredis à cet
atelier d'improvisation théâtrale à tra
ici on va apprendre à s'améliorer au mal
d'informations on va prendre soin des
techniques et puis c'est là aussi que
les jeunes c'est dans cet espace là bon
là qui vont pouvoir tenter de nouvelles
choses des nouveaux personnages objectif
pourrait être à l'aise à l'oral et
apprendre à mieux s'exprimer et à
s'affirmer pour ces jeunes c'est aussi
un lien d'amitié qui se crée j'ai
commencé ce appareil vers la 6e et ça
m'a tout de suite plu parce qu'en fait
avant j'étais très timide et où est
justement grâce à l'impro et bassam a
aidé plus m'ouvrir aux autres et à
pouvoir parler en public sans être
stressé et tous ses biens en être avec
le public parce que moi ça me fait
plaisir quand j'arrive à faire rire les
gens donc je viens pas forcément pour le
public mais je viens surtout pour
m'amuser on est tout le temps là pour
apprendre pour aller vers le positif ils
nous montrent vers le haut mais il nous
descendent jamais ces ateliers sont
animés par des comédiens issus de déclic
théâtre comme alexandra elle a commencé
l'impro à l'adolescence après avoir
obtenu une place dans la compagnie elle
mène maintenant des ateliers les valeurs
qu'on m'a appris d'improvisation je
trouve ça très important mais et si on
peut les transmettre et ça passe par
l'apprentissage donc c'est à gauche trop
important de 9 à 18 ans les enfants
apprennent donc tout et techniques de
l'improvisation jusqu'à en faire
peut-être pour certains leur métier
alors viens de le voir donc un atelier
d'improvisation quel est le but
finalement de faire de l'improvisation
le but c'est de se découvrir moi je moi
je dis je dis souvent que l'on en fait
on a facilement accès à la chanson parle
par l'école au dessin c'est un art voilà
parées aux sports donc on peut se
découvrir au milieu scolaire dans ces
disciplines n'a pour le théâtre c'est
plus compliqué il n'y a pas de théâtre
ou de cours de théâtre à proprement dit
dans le cul sur dans le cursus scolaire
donc c'est vrai que c'est et on peut
effectivement se découvrir une passion à
laquelle il faut s'essayer ou à laquelle
il faut se forcer à les convaincre de
d'élèves sont inscrits
alors on dénombre en moyenne 500 500
bénéficiaires à 500 jeunes de l'école
élémentaire au lycée chaque année
alors de nombreux élèves désormais
connus sont passés par déclic et nous
avons fait une petite liste non
exhaustive bien sûr
[Musique]
seras tu m'as bien ouais d'umaru château
know what he
[Musique]
en fait ce spectacle il se résume en
trois mots force résilience en fait je
suis parti d'ici
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qu'on est là on est en train
de disputer la vallée de l'agout vous
m'avez coupe et le zinc
c'est anormal vous aurez qu prévenir
avant moi si j'ai quand même conservé 1
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non j'ai souscrit une excellente
muchacho dire la vérité voilà déjà tu
crois que j'ai une frange pas du tout
jaloux mais klopp à la gazinière
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bekkat on a voulu sortir harry châble
pour les femmes voilées pour leur
permettre de faire du sport oh
les fachos ça leur a fait chauffer le
bocal il était à sa de dry leur seul
neurone alors géraldine orquera à part
les matchs d'improvisation disons
classique à on vous organisez aussi
actuellement les phases de finale donc
de la 23e édition du championnat inter
collèges de match d'improvisation
théâtrale de saint quentin en yvelines
c'est un projet donc d'éducation
artistique un établi et donc dans 14
collèges de saint quentin en yvelines
comment ça va se dérouler cette soirée
du 3 e l'an prochain à l'analyse alors
on va accueillir les élèves des quatre
collèges finalistes donc les quatre
collèges c'est le collège le village
le village giacometti
au sol et anatole france donc on va
accueillir les élèves dès 18 heures à la
mairie ils vont pouvoir se rencontrer
sans traîner un petit peu s'échauffer
découvrir la salle aussi parce que c'est
la première fois de l'année qu'ils vont
jouer dans une salle aussi importante
est vaste que la merise le match
d'improvisation théâtrale c'est aussi
tous les mouvements qui a qui sont
importants qu'il ya en dehors les
ateliers bien évidemment mais ces
moments où aussi on se retrouve ensemble
ou on découvre les uns les autres on
rencontre les coaches des différentes
équipes et après on va avoir
effectivement nos deux demi finales
suivies de la finale en dernière partie
de soirée autre axe très important de la
compagnie la radio marmite fm qui est né
en 2001 et donc les locaux sont situés
juste à côté et puis moi je propose
qu'on compte bien y aller
[Musique]
on se retrouve dans les studios donc de
la radio marmite fm si tu n'auras du
dong locales à vocation citoyenne
éducatives et culturelles géraldine mort
car pourquoi travailler avec le radio
effectivement c'est un peu atypique pour
une compagnie théâtre d'avoir aussi une
radio je crois que c'est inédit en
france mais ça a tout son sens en fait
parce qu'il ya un véritable adn commun
entre la compagnie théâtre et la radio
donc on est vraiment sur la liberté
d'expression
artistique ou plus informative nous
sommes rendus dans les studios nous de
marmites fm nous avons rencontré un
nouradine agne le reporter de la radio
de pirouettes sur les ondes de marmites
fm 88 points 4 avec lui en direct sur
88.4 nouradine a nié journalistes pour
marmite fm et au micro et le recevait
cet après-midi-là deux comédiens qui
prépare un festival d'improvisation
théâtrale sur saint quentin en yvelines
dans l'émission-phare marmite et son
actu d'abord on essaie d'inviter une
personnalité locale qui a une actualité
à chaque émission il ya un journal
d'actualités par la mesure il est à
préparer donc il ya des reportages qui
sont faits sur sur la semaine ce
programme est présenté en direct tous
les mercredis dès 17 heures à 18 heures
en tout ce sont une vingtaine des
missions variées on peut parler autant
de littérature du livre que d'économie
on parle également avec l'émission trapy
blog par exemple de l'actualité des
jeunes de trappes qui ont 15 16 17 ans
et qui ont vu de s'exprimer un petit peu
sur les problématiques qui la
rencontrent au quotidien dans cette
radio 60% des programmes sont réalisés
par des bénévoles c'est l'adn de
marmites fm depuis sa création c'est à
dire que c'est bas des habitants de des
habitants de saint quentin en yvelines
qui ont un projet d'émission qui vont
venir nous le soumettre on essaie
vraiment rapidement une fois qu'une
personne est motivée envie de faire la
radio et surtout a quelque chose à dire
eh bien on ouvre la porte on essaie de
lui donner en tout cas les clés de
compréhension de comment marche la radio
puis après c'est parti entre 25 à 30
bénévoles produisent des émissions ou
des rnic régulièrement la radio peut
également s'écouter sur le site internet
avec tous les podcasts les programmes de
cette radio sont réalisées à 60% par des
bénévoles pour cela ils doivent être
formés aux exigences du média nous en
avons rencontré quelques dents
aujourd'hui on est en formation parce
que comme on est des bénévoles on n'est
pas des journalistes
on a tous besoin d apprendre des
techniques pour améliorer nos émissions
on est tous ensemble on fait des
exercices pour l'instant on est avec les
via langues donc c'est apprendre à
articuler et puis on se rencontre aussi
pourquoi le bénévolat mais parce qu'ils
ont bien voulu m'accueillir aussi pour
mon ma mission de diffusion de poésie
donc j enregistre régulièrement des ce
que j'appelle des confettis poétiques
sont des virgules de radio qui sont
utilisés pour passer d'une émission à
l'autre donc j'ai toute la liberté du
choix des textes alors une dernière
question avant la fin de l'émission là
est ce que vous pouvez manon c'est
peut-être les prochains grands rendez
vous et des déclic théâtre alors au delà
de la finale du stic mythe vendredi 3
juin à la merise on a notre grand rendez
vous de fin de saison total déclic qui
est un tournoi intergénérationnel le
vendredi 1er juillet au conservatoire de
musique et de danse à trappes et là on
va retrouver des équipes constituées de
d'enfants d'ados de l'adulte amateurs et
professionnels donc nos benjamins cadets
juniors et épices de trappes donc ça
s'éteint c'est le grand rendez vous de
fin de saison et puis pour vertigo pour
ouvrir la prochaine saison
là c'est trappe impro family 7 là c'est
un match d'impro avec des comédiens
professionnels c'est le 18 novembre à la
merise attrape
un autre rendez-vous à eux non mais oh
peut-être dire a ajouté que voilà c'est
céder 30 ans et du coup de déclic et du
coup toutes ces attelages l'année
prochaine donc trappe à prendre il y va
être voilà le premier évènement de cette
année particulière pour la compagnie
merci beaucoup géraldine marquera nour
ali akin louise d'avoir été nos invités
et c'est la fin déjà donc de cette
émission 7,8 culture merci beaucoup de
nous avoir suivis bonne soirée sur tf1
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]